What does it mean if you have low albumin? So albumin is a protein that is
released by your liver. So that's what you look at on a complete blood count. So it's one of your
major blood proteins. And it helps to transport hormones around your blood. Now if it's low,
what could that mean? So low albumin and low total protein is also considered what's called an
ominous sign. So if I just didn't have a diagnosis of cancer, not at all, didn't even consider
to have cancer. I went in for my yearly physical and I showed a low total protein, low albumin,
low globulin. Those would be considered ominous signs for hum. It should make the doctor go hum.
I got to dig a little bit deeper and see what's going on. So a person can have liver dysfunction.
That's causing low albumin. A person could have cancer that's causing low albumin. Now you look
for other ominous signs. If you don't diagnose cancer over a CBC and a complete metabolic
panel, but if I had elevated alcohol and phosphatase with low albumin, that would make me question,
you know, start digging into possible other tests to run to see what's causing this because it could
be a cancer. Or if I had also my cholesterol, without taking any medication or making any giant
adjustments, went from being 200 last year to 135 this year, this huge drop in cholesterol,
that would be a huge ominous sign for cancer as well. They're called ominous signs because they
just say, hum, something's going on and we got to figure this out. Hypochloridria can cause low albumin
too. So that's a possibility, but you correlate that with some other tests and I go over all those
other tests that should help diagnose hypochloridria, the blood tests on my blog on hypochloridria.
Remember hypochloridria is too hydrochloric acid in your stomach, which is probably the most
common morbidity known to man, and it can cause the greatest disorders. So that's what you look for.
So low albumin by itself leads something, but we don't know what it means until we look at
in correlation to other labs and correlations to other findings. And that's the way it is
honestly with a lot of blood tests, okay, so it means something, okay, even like we said,
elevated white blood cell count. What does that mean? Does that mean they have infection? Well,
maybe we have to correlate it with other things, you know, low red blood cell count. Does it mean
epidemia? Well, maybe we have to correlate with other things. So everything, all your blood tests are
clues. They give us clues to something going on and you've got to go to a doctor that is digging
into the differential diagnosis of what that clue means. And that's what I've tried to give you with
the, I added a ton of stuff under the labs and testings piece of the member site. So make sure you go
to that and help you, you know, understand labs to help you unravel the clues when you look at
your labs, because we are finding more and more that doctor, so you're by going and you have labs
ordered by your oncologist, they sell them go over them. I just mind boggling to you. Why do you run
up if you're not going to go over them? I don't understand, but that's just the way it is.